long distance wait outside the Warriors
are headed back to the NBA Finals in
part thanks to a big night from star
Steph Curry
last night's overtime win clinched a
sweep of the Portland Trail Blazers and
now Golden State is just the second team
in NBA history to make five consecutive
appearances in the finals CBS News
correspondent and CBS n anchor vladimir
duthiers is here with another more
personal stat for the record books
Vlad good morning good morning Warriors
start Steph Curry is not contending for
his fourth NBA championship getting
there met battling his younger brother
Seth Curry it's the first time siblings
have faced off in an NBA Conference
final leaving the curry family a house
divided from the time they were kids
Steph and Seth Curry were destined to be
basketball rivals and one step from the
finals fate once again hitted the
brothers against each other the club
that's up to the state of as he walks
past their friendly jabs emanating
across the court this was like the
coolest experience I think I've ever had
playing you know against him this is
Charlie didn't make it tough on
stress their proud parents watch
nervously from the crowd we thought it
would be a lot of fun it's not so much
fun it was really hard getting ourselves
prepared for not being all in for one
child by far the hardest decision for
the family who to support and how we
kind of figured out a way to make it
work
Shelley Bain brink Steph Curry's
godmother and a family friend of 35
years had an idea creating split jerseys
so Sonia and Dell curry could cheer for
both of their boys last night
Steph got the better of his younger
brother in a thrilling overtime win but
even as he moves on to play in another
NBA final he's looking toward his
brothers future me somebody had to lose
but this is just the beginning for him
and his career will remember this for
the rest of our lives despite losing to
his big brother Seth says there are no
hard feelings I believe that clinics
changed jerseys are the it is so cool
but they are such so tight as a family
it's good to love that family oh yeah
congratulations
thank you